with super bowl sunday just days away
the star-studded commercials continue to
roll in
the latest mike myers rob lowe harry guy
mike myers roblo smooth guy yeah yes
the cast of boston powers reunite as
they team up with general motors to
promote electric cars in an effort to
help save the planet
bye
ladies and gentlemen our takeover of
general motors is complete dr abel gm's
ultim platform will power our whole
operation now we can reduce tailpipe
emissions oh please cheer for my son
your son
i shall name him
baby me no his name is kyle
[Applause]
you must help save the world first then
you can take over the world hold on i've
got it i will help save the world first
then take over the world she literally
just said that
scott you just don't get it do you what
you didn't get are you right back you're
gonna you can't draw me in my body you
act like a child you can't push my
buttons anymore
we'll reduce our carbon footprint okay
let's go we're going all electric
everybody in
not you scar
bye bye baby
[Music]